ساكن هانت عندكم روسي
مكانها الحاليه وقت تصوير الحلقه زي ما
انتم شايفين قدامكم كده في سفن واقفه في
المواني اما بتحمل او بتفضي نفط وفي نقلات
ثانيه بتتحرك في عرض البحر طبعا كل سفينه
نقدر نعرف قصه حياتها كلها رايحه فين
وجايه منين وهتوصل للدوله اللي رايحه لها
امتى وحولتها قد ايه ومين اللي صنعناها
ومين مالكها دلوقت ونقدر نعمل تتبع لخطرها
كل حاجه تقريبا يعني مثلا بصوا على
الناقله اللي ماشيه في وسط خليك في فنلندا
اتجاه روسيا دي الناقله اسمها زي ما هو
واضح قدامكم جامد مدينه منجلور في الهند
ورايحه مدينه
وده مسارها قدامكم على الشاشه لحد ما توصل
عند مدينه بريمارسك واللي بالمناسبه فيها
اكبر ميناء في بحر البطيخ بعد النداء
بشكل طبيعي ان احنا هتحمل وترجع ثاني على
الهامد طبعا زي ما واضح قدامكم خلينا برده
نشوف المسار بتاع الرجوع بتاعها بتلف وبعد
كده بتدخل بحر المتوسط بتعدي من قناه
السويس للبحر الاحمر ثم بعد كده بتكمل لحد
مانجولار تعالوا بينا نشوف شويه معلومات
برده عن الناقله املي اس زي ما واضح
قدامنا كده هي غداره من الهند في 7 نوفمبر
وتبنت في 2006 يعني عمرها 16 سنه وبتبحر
تحت علم بنها طاقتها الاستيعابيه من الوزن
الساكن حوالي 116,000 طن كل التفاصيل
المتعلقه بها نقدر نوصلها زي ما واضح
قدامكم روسيا هي ثاني اكبر مصدر لنفط
الخام في العالم لحد نصف السنه الحاليه
2022 كانت معتمد على سفن اجنبيه لنقل
نقطها الخيال ولكن اخر كم شهر بدانا نلاحظ
ظهوره مشترين اسمعهم مش معروفه في سوق شحن
النفط بيشتروا نقلات
كامله كده من بابها وفجاه بنلاقي انقلات
دي بتروح راسي اللي بيحصل بقى ان روسيا
بتبني اسطول من نقلات النفط الخاص بها
علشان تصدر بين حطها للصين والهند وتركيا
اسطول ظل زي ما قصاد شحن النفط سمته
الفتره اللي فاتت المقدمه دي اكيد هتخليكم
تفكروا في شويه اسئله مهمه وخطيره ايه قصه
اسطول الظل اللي روسيا بتبنيه ده عباره عن
ايه بالضبط وهيفيدها في ايه ويعني ايه فرد
حد اقصى او سقف لاسعار النفط الروسيه ولسه
ده اتحدد ب 60 دولار يعني ليه مش اقل او
اكثر وايه تاثير القرار ده على روسيا وعلى
سوق النفطه العالمي دي عينه من الاسئله
اللي هنحاول نجاوب عليها مع بعض في حلقه
النهارده لكن قبل ما نبدا بافكركم
بالاشتراك في القناه اشتركم هو اللي
بيخلينا نكمل ونحافظ على جوده شغلنا ونوره
عيني فباطلب من اللي لسه ما اشتركش منكم
في القناه انه يشترك وفعله الجرس
التنبيهات علشان يوصل لكم محتوانا جديد
اول باول وكمان بافكركم ان كل حلقاتنا من
اول السنه مترجمه للانجليزيه تقدر بسهوله
تفعل الترجمه بالضغط على زرار السيسي
وتقدر بكده تشارك الحلقه دي وكل حلقاتنا
اللي فاتت من اول 2020 مع اي صديق او
صديقه مشعره يلا بينا نبدا انا اشرف
ابراهيم ده المخلق الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
حلقه دي برعايه شركه كابرس وهي شركه وساطه
ماليه عالميه ومرخصه من قبل هيئه تنظيم
الخدمات الماليه في سوق ابو ظبي العالمي
اي دي جي ام بالاضافه لامتلاكها العديد من
التراخيص كاميكس بتقدم فرص تداول متميزه
من خلال مجموعه متنوعه من الادوات الماليه
زي الاسهم والعملات والمقشرات والسندات
والعملات المشفرهم هتلاقوا رابط لهم في
وصف الفيديو في تعليقات فيسبوك
الحروب بشكل عام مكلفه جدا من كل النواحي
ولو اي دوله ما فيش معها فوائد ماليه
كبيره او لها مصادر دخل دولاريه محترمه
ومستقره فمش هتقدر تكمل العركه اللي داخله
فيها والموضوع هينتهي بهزيمتها او انسحبها
في اواخر شهر فبراير اللي فات الجيش
الروسي بدا يجتاح الاراضي الاوكرانيه ومن
وقتها ولحد دلوقت روسيا من ناحيه
واوكرانيا ومن وراها الدول الغربيه من
ناحيه ثانيه نازلين طحن في بعض على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه يعني بنتكلم في حرب
بقالها تقريبا 10 شهور مستمر كل ده رغم
كميه العقوبات اللي لم تفرض على دوله في
التاريخ من حيث حجمها وتاثيرها واللي
فرضتها الدول الغربيه على روسيا خلال ال
10 شهور دول احد الاسباب الرئيسيه لصمود
روسيا وفشل العقوبات الغربيه لحد اللحظه
دي في اجبارها على التراجع ولا انسحاب من
اوكرانيا هو حنفيه الارادات الضخمه اللي
داخله لها واللي مصدرها صادرات النفط والغ
روسي وفقا لوزاره الماليه الروسيه فمتوقع
ان الصادرات روسيا من النفط والغاز في شكل
42% من اجمالي ارادتها في 2022 يعني
تقريبا بنتكلم عن ايرادات هتوصل ل 196
مليون دولار رغم العقوبات الغربيه اللي ما
لهاش عدد اللي اتفردت عليها الشيء اللي
لفت للنظر هنا ان الايرادات دي اكثر من
ارادات السنه اللي فاتت 2021 بحوالي 36%
واللي كانت قيمتها 152 مليار دولار الدول
العربيه وقتها قالت بس الحل بسيطه اهو
احنا نقفل لهم الحنفيه اللي بتنزل لهم
مليارات الدولارات دي فاجتمع زعماء
الاتحاد الاوروبي في 30 مايو اللي فات
ووافقوا على فرد حزمه ثابته من العقوبات
على روسيا بما فيها فرد حظر جزء على اعلى
نفط روسي اعتبارا من خمسه ديسمبر الحالي
طب ليه بنقول حظر جزء لانه حظر على وردات
الروس المنقوله بحرا للاتحاد الاوروبي ولا
يشمل طبعا النفط اللي رايح من خلالها
الخطوط الانابيه طيب ده كلام حلو قوي بس
في مشكله واحده بس ان الحظر ده معناه ان
كميات النفط اللي روسيا بالضحاها في سوق
النفط العالمي هتقل وبالتالي الاسعار
هتزيد ودي اكثر حاجه مؤذيه الاقتصادات
الدول الغربيه وتحديدا ولايات المتحده
ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي قرار حظر
نفطر روسي هيضرب في وش الدول دي وهيبقوا
بالضبط زي اللي بيضرب بالرصاصه على رجله
لان الحظر ده هيرفع معدلات التضخم اكتر ما
هي عاليه عندهم وبالتالي المستهلكين ما هم
شعوبهم يعني هيتفرموا في النصف وده اللي
حصل بالفعل بعد فرض الحظر الاوروبي على
النفط الروسي ارتفعت اسعار خام برنت
مستويات قياسيه وتخطت ال120 دولار للبرميل
وطبعا مستويات اسعار النفطه دي بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده تعتبر
فوضى جوه اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايتنز
لانها بتاثر مباشره على دخول الامريكيين
مستويات معاشاته ان احنا ك- اداره امريكيه
بنشوف عقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي دي صارمه
جدا وهتتسبب لنا في كوارث لانها هتقطع
الامدادات الروسيه وهترفع اسعار النفط
لمستويات غير مسبوق فهنا الاداره
الامريكيه فضلت تفكر في حلل المعضله دي
لحد موازنه الخزانه الامريكيه جانتلن قالت
لهم الحل عندي احنا هنسيب النفط الروسي
يتباع ويتداول في السوق عادي ولكن هنفرض
سقف سعر عليه وبالتالي يبقى من ناحيه
سماحنا اللي نفطر روسي ينزل السوق وبكده
المعروض هيفضل زي ما هو والاسعار مش هتزيد
ومن ناحيه ثانيه قال لنا الايرادات
النفطيه اللي بتدخل في جيب الاقتصاد
الروسي ايه الحل كان ذكي وعلى طول بيض انا
اقتنع به وسافر المانيا بعد اقل من شهر من
قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي وحظر النفط روسي
علشان يبلغ الاوروبيين بيه وقدره الولايات
المتحده بالفعل تقنع على الاتحاد الاوروبي
مجموعه الدول السبع كبرى بفكره فرد برايس
كاب او سقف اسعار للناس الراسي فضل بقى
الدولات والمشورات بين الدول دي كلها على
مدار الشهور اللي فاتت على اليه التنفيذ
وتحديد السقف ده هيكون كم دولار لبرميل
بالضبط وفي 5 ديسمبر اللي فات فرضت مجموعه
الدول السبع اللي بتضم الولايات المتحده و
كندا وفرنسا والمانيا وايطاليا وبريطانيا
واليابان بالاضافه الاستراليا وال27 دوله
من الاتحاد الاوروبي فرضوا سقف الاسعار
النفطاروس الخام اللي بتنقله وتحدد السقف
ده ب 60 دولار البرميل ومباشره من وقتها
دخل الحظر حيز التنفيذ لكن مع فتره
الانتقاليه مدتها 45 يوم بتسمح للسفن اللي
تم تحميلها قبل خمسه ديسمبر انها تنقل
الحمولتها وتفرغها بحلول 19 يناير كحد
اقصى من غير عقوبات طيب خلونا نسال سؤال
مهم ايه الهدف للفرد سقف اسعار ب60$
لبرميل النفط الروسيه الهدف يا جماعه انهم
يسمحوا الدول الثانيه من خارج الاتحاد
الاوروبي
استيراد النفط الروسي عادي ولكن عند السقف
ده مش اكثر وبالتالي هيضمنوا استقرار
اسعار النفطه العالميه وفي نفس الوقت
هيقللوا الايرادات اللي داخله لراسي حد
فيكم كان مركز مع اسئله المقدمه هيسالني
لي اشرف 60 دولار تحديدا مش اكثر او اقل
لان الرقم ده قريب من سعر خامه النفط
الروسي يعني خامه القرار كان وصل ل 67$
برميل اوائل شهر ديسمبر فاحنا ما بعدناش
كثير طب ليه هم اتفق
وا على قريب من السعر لروسيا بتبيع بيه هل
حب عن في روسيا مثلا اقول لك لا طبعا
الدول الغربيه ولا مشاركه في فرد عقوبات
على رؤوس تتمنى انها تاخذ النفط روسي
ببلاش كل ما في الامر انهم خايفين لو
حددوا سعر منخفض جدا روسيا تقوم قلبك
ترابيزه على الكل وتخفض انتاجها النفطي
وبالتالي ترفع الاسعار العالميه لمستويات
جنونيه لكن مع سعره قريب من السعر اللي هي
بتبيع به فهما بيتوقعوا ان روسيا هيكون
عندها حافز لمواصله الضغط الخام حتى لو
ارادتها هتقل شويه هنا حد ممكن يسال سؤال
منطقي بقى هل الكلام دولار دول في البرميل
الواحد هيفرقه فعلا اقول لك طبعا هيفرقه
لو سعر الخامه الروسي في الطبيعي كان معدي
ال 60 دولار البرميل اللي هو السقف رئيسه
استونيا كتبت التغريده اللي قدام حضراتكم
دي يوم الاثنين ديسمبر وقالت فيها ان كل
دولار مهم كل دولار تم التفاوض عليه
وتخفيضه واحنا بنحدد سقف السعر معناه
داخله اقل لروسيا بحوالي 2 مليار دولار
واقتراح سقف السعر في الاول كان 65 دولار
فهي بتشكر الدول انهم وافقوا على تقليله ل
60 دولار وده معناه ايرادات ب 10 مليار
دولار اقل بالنسبه لروسيا لتمويل حرب
الاباده الجماعيه ضد الاوكرانيين على حد
كلامها طيب هنا سؤال رئيسي ثاني ممكن احد
يساله ازاي مجموعه الدول السبع والاتحاد
الاوروبي واستراليا هيفرضوا على السوق سعر
محدد لازم الدول اللي هتشتري من روسيا
هتشتري بيه هيعملوها ازاي دول يعني دوله
الهند عايزه تستوردنا في روسي ده 65 دولار
ولا ب 70 دولار البرميل مثلا والهند هتطلع
تقول انا مساج كده هتفرده علي ان ما ينفعش
اشتري غير بالستين دول او اقل ازاي
هتلزمني اصلا كان نظام هندي ده حاجه زي
كده ازاي الدول الغربيه كان عندها حل
للموضوع ده فعل احنا مش هنسمح لشركات
التامين واعاده التامين التابعه لمجموعه
الدول السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
انهم يقدموا خدمات للنقلات اللي شايله نفط
روسي سعره اكثر من السقف اللي هو 60 دولار
ومش هنسمح للمؤسسات اللي بتمول معاملات
النفط الخام الروسي انها تتعامل مع
الشحنات اللي سعرها معدي ال 60 دولار ولا
هنسمح لشركات الشحن اللي تبعنا انها توفر
ناقلات لنقل النفط الخام الروسي الا اذا
كان سعر بيع النفط بسكتين دولار او اقل
المشكله هنا بقى يا اخواننا ان مجموعه
الدول السبع بتتحمل مسؤوليه 90% من جميع
تامينات شحن العالميه يعني ايه ده علشان
حضراتكم تكونوا معي في الصوره اي ناقله
نفط في العالم لازم يكون متامن عليها
وبالتالي الوضع دلوقت ان ما فيش ناقله نفط
هتقدر تشيل نفط روسي باكثر من 60 دولار
للبرميل علشان شركات التامين مش هتوافق
اصلا تؤمن عليها الا بقى لو كانت مستعده
تشيل الشحنه وتتحرك في عرض البحر من غير
تامين شركه من الشركات التابعه لمجموعه
الدول السابع دي حاجه صعبه جدا لانه مش
متوقع اللي ممكن يحصل لناقله دي باي شكل
واي سبب مهم جدا تعرفه ان روسيا بتصدر
يوميا حوالي ثمانيه مليون برميل نفط من
المنتجات الخام والمكرره ودي كميه ضخمه
جدا ومحتاجه عدد كبير من الصافي والسفن
الموجوده مش هتقدر تشيل نفط سعره ومعدي
السقف علشان التامين وفي نفس الوقت روسي
عندها مشكله انها كانت معتمده بشكل كبير
على ناقلات اجنبيه لنقل الخم بتاعها
وبالتالي بعد العقوبات دي سواء الحظر اللي
فرضه الاتحاد الاوروبي على الواردات
المنقوله بحرا او السقف العالمي للناس
تروسي عند 60 دولار هيتم عزل روسيا عن جزء
كبير من اسطول الناقلات العالميه ف ازاي
روسيا هتواجه الوضع ده بقى هنا يجي رد
روسي الشيء اللي بقى مؤكد قدامنا دلوقت ان
روسيا بتبني سلاسه الامداد خاصه بها علشان
ما تبقاش تحت رحمه لا مجموعه السبع ولا
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي بيعرفها بالسعر
اللي هي عايزاه ثلاثه بجد هي اسطول الظل
بتاعها سمسار الشحن العالمي شركه بلايمار
بتقول ان روسيا اشترت اكثر من 100 سفينه
خلال السنه دي من خلال عمليات شراء مباشره
او غير مباشره شركه استشارات الطاقه
ريستاد اتاكد الكلام ده وبتقول ان روسيا
اضافت 103 ناقله نفط خلال 2022 من خلال
عمليات الشراء واعاده تخصيص السفن اللي
بتخدم ايرانوفينزويلا وهم دولتين زي
محضراتكم عارفين المفروض عليهم حظر ناس
غرب ايه الكلمه دي خبيره نفطر روسي في
مركز جامعه هارفار والبيتبع تراكم السفن
الروسيه بيقول ان انا في الشهور الاخيره
شفنا عدد كبير من المبيعات لمشترين ما
كشفوش عن اسمهم بعد اسابيع قليله من البيع
بتظهر الناقلات دي في روسيا وهي بتحمل اول
شحنه من النفط الخام هدف روسيا من تكوين
اسطول الظل ده هو محاوله التحايل والتغلب
على القيود الغربيه الجديده المفروض على
مبيعات الناس بعد بدء تطبيق الحظر
الاوروبي او سقف الاسعار من يوم خمسه
ديسمبر اللي فات روسيا قالت انها مش
هتتعامل مع اي دوله هتطبق سقف الاسعار ده
وهتستخدم اسطولها الجديد علشان تمد دواء
زي الهند والصين وتركيا اللي اصبحوا اكبر
مشترين لما نفطر روسي بعد تراجع المبيعات
للاتحاد الاوروبي شركه بريمار قالت لو
اكلت الطاقه الدوليه في عرض تقديم الشهر
اللي فات ان المشغلين المرتبطين بروسيا
اشتروا حوالي 29 ناقل في نفخه عملاقه
والمعروف اختصارا يبقى فيه ال سي سي او
فيري لارج كروت كاريس دي بتقدر تشيل اكثر
من اثنين مليون برميل واشتروا واحده 31 من
ناقله بحجم سوس ماكس ودي السفن الضخمه
اللي تقدر تعدي قناه السويس وبتقدر تشيل
مليون برميل من النفط واشتغل وتسعه
واربعين طلع افرع ماكس ودي تقدر تشيل
حوالي 700,000 برميل متوقع ان روسيا
هتتكمل بناء اسطول الظل بتاعها وهتستمر في
عمليات شراء نقلات وبالذات من الحجم اللي
عملاق لان الرحلات دلوقتي بقى الطويله
الاول كان النفط بيروح اوروبا جنبها دلوقت
هيروح لدول في اسيا فالمسافه زادت جدي
اكيد اسطول الظل الروسي هيقلل من تاثير
الاجراءات العقبيه على النفط الروسي ولكنه
مش هيقضي عليها وهتفضل روسيا عندها مشكله
في الحفاظ على مستويات صادراتها طبيعه
الحال انا كده خلصت كلام وفي النهايه
هاسالكم سؤال مهم في رايكم تفتكروا اسطول
السفن الروسيه هيتغلب على عقوبه المفتي
الغربيه ولا الروس هيقرروا يقلبه
الترابيزه ويخفضوا انتاجهم وبالتالي
يرفعوا الاسعار في العالم كله هتابع
اجابتكم كلها في التعليقات ما تنسوش
تشوفوا خدمات شركه من خلال اللينك في وصف
الفيديو ما تنسوش الاشتراك في القناه زي
ما اتفقنا وياريت لو عجبكم الحلقه دي
تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو وما تنسوش تحكم
لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن يستفيد وتحكم
لاصحابكم الاجانب عننا وتوريهم الحلقات
بالترجمه
سلام
[موسيقى]